Jersey Shore stars Holly D and Vinny are
hoping for a double shot at love with
their hit MTV show it actually set
ratings records for MTV and it is pretty
easy to see why 20 women and two best
friends looking for their Ryder dives
double shot at love is pretty much what
you get if the bachelor and Jersey Shore
had a reality TV baby but instead of
Rose ceremonies contestants are sent
home at cab ceremonies it's a little
different I'm not yelling it you know
like as a hip but now this was a little
bit more formal not quite as formal as
bachelor but a little warmer than Jersey
shows it's a really tense moment Ali I'm
sorry have is here it gets heated we
have security on-premise and tomorrow
it's Vinny who's turning up the heat in
Vegas starting a month run as
Chippendales guest host you lost 50
pounds thanks to the keto diet and this
keto widow says his Jersey Shore fam is
coming to watch they're all gonna come
and I don't know if I should be
embarrassed or mortified or excited that
they're going to come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]